[Musik]
hallo ihr lieben heute machen die
menschen öfter das könnte als beilage
essen ist sehr gesund und sehr sättigend
wir benötigen 400 gramm rote linsen 160
gramm feingold 80 gramm olivenöl 8 150
milliliter wasser bei esther internat
axel dierolf einen teelöffel tomatenmark
und ein laptop die camargue ein
teelöffel salz 1 teelöffel paprikapulver
außerdem eine zitrone eine handvoll
petersilie ein paar stammkunden und zwei
normale zwiebeln die zwiebeln sowie die
petersilie habe ich bereits klein
geschnitten und weiter geht's auf dem
herd das olivenöl wird im topf erhitzen
und die zwiebeln darin gerüstet
[Musik]
anschließend kommt das tomatenmark und
das publikum mag hinzu und wird mit
bedeutet
dazu kommen dann noch die gewürze und
das granatapfel sirup und alles wird gut
miteinander verrührt
petersilie kommt ganz zum schluss hinein
die gebe ich erstmal angeleitet und
weiter geht's mit den linden und dem
burghof die linsen habe ich unter kaltem
wasser abgespült gebe dass in meinem
kopf und dann kommt noch das opfer hinzu
und wird einmal aufgekauft nach dem
aufkochen gebe ich den deckel drüber
das ganze sollte jetzt ca 20 minuten
lang quellen dabei müsst ihr aber immer
wieder umrühren damit auf dem dachboden
nichts anbrennen die linsen verlieren
dann an farbe und werden weich und jetzt
kann das buch hinzugegeben werden
der deckel wird dann verschlossen und
das ganze muss noch mal fünf minuten
lang fehlen
in den topf geben wir jetzt noch das
vorbereitete gemüse von vorhin und das
ganze wird gut untergerührt das ganze
sollte sich sehr gut miteinander
verbinden und erhaltet dann eine teig
artige konsequent wenn sich das ganze
gut verbunden hat wird noch der
zitronensaft hinein geprägt das ganze
dann noch mal gut umrühren und zu guter
letzt gehen wir die petersilie hinzu und
dann ist die masse auch schon fertig nun
möchten die menschen mehr kräfte nur
noch geformt werden ob er das längliche
macht oder rund ist vollkommen euch
überlassen
bis zum verzehr werden die menschen mehr
gibt es jetzt im kühlschrank gelagert
und am besten die zweite folie über
ziehen damit sie auch nicht austrocknen
am besten schmecken sie dann wenn ihr
sie mit salat zitronensaft und
granatapfel wir observiert ich wünsche
euch ganz viel spaß im nass machen und
wenn ihr keines meiner videos verpassen
möchte dann abonniert mich doch gerne
bis zum nächsten mal auf die gis kitchen
[Musik]